if you find your passion
you're gonna have this tremendous energy
it's sustainable energy but momentum
requires you always do the next thing to
keep the momentum going and the reason
you get yourself in a passionate place
is so that you change your life and the
only thing that changes your life is
making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you're like oh
i don't know what do you think all right
let's decide if you make a decision in a
state without momentum if you make a
decision from a place where there's no
passion you are not going to get
momentum it'll kill momentum it's decide
commit
and resolve
some of you
in the past you've gotten momentum
you've gotten passionate you've even
made a decision but a decision is the
first step decision is like a war i
gotta do this or that all right i'm
gonna make myself do this but commitment
is when you now after you've decided you
commit to do this for the long term
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter
you're doing this
it takes it from this moment and it
carries you to the future even when
things are difficult
and the third state is resolve resolve
means it's done it's like it doesn't
even if you took action it's done inside
you so it's done out there there's no
question whatsoever
then once you decide
the only way the commitment and the
energy and the momentum continues is if
you take immediate massive what my
friends massive what write down in your
notes massive action is the cure-all
massive action is the cure-all if you're
having a difficult time with something
your relationship isn't where you want
it to be your finances are not where you
want to be your body's not where you
want to be your business is not where
you want to be you need to take massive
action and if that doesn't work try
something else if that doesn't work try
something else keep going with massive
action and you will find the way because
it will give you momentum
the first thing most people do after
they make a decision is they plan they
strategize they tinker they think and
it's the worst thing you can do here's
why you make a bold decision you say i'm
gonna change my life i'm gonna go off
and do this crazy amazing thing and then
you go home and you think of all the
ways that you can happen and you start
planning and strategizing is amazing you
feel great and then you wake up tomorrow
and you're a different person
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and that person said you can't do that
you can't follow through on that who are
you to take on that big idea and then
nothing happens
nothing happens and so the solution
after you get immediate idea is action
don't worry about planning
even imperfect action just action
because you need to build it into your
nervous system that you're the kind of
person who follows through because you
need to make some commitment so that by
the time you wake up tomorrow you've
committed to following through that's
the biggest problem i call the two
percent difference so what most people
will do is they'll plan to 100 you get
an idea you got a plan you got to go
home you got a plan plan plan plan you
got to plan all the way to the end and
it's amazing and you think about it it's
such a great place to live in as
entrepreneurs as perfectionists as over
planners we love living in that world
don't worry about planning to 100
instead find the two percent difference
what can you do right now to get two
percent of the way if you don't get two
percent of the way immediately through
action you will never get to 100 of the
way so an example i'm i'm sitting here
standing here walking here on the
streets of san francisco i'm in the
middle of my 90-day tour across 23
cities this thing started because i
committed to my wife that i was going to
take her to every city in north america
with a million plus people it was a warm
summer day and i said nina we're going
to go to every city in north america
with one million plus people it was a
wednesday afternoon so what was the
first step it's not going home and
planning to see how many cities are
there i don't even know how many cities
are there no idea
it's not planning about how is nina
going to leave her job because she had a
full-time job it's not planning about
how long is going to take none of that
don't go home and start researching that
it's the wrong first step
the first step is what's the one city
that i can hit immediately it's
wednesday afternoon what's one city i
can go to this weekend to start building
immediate momentum the two percent
difference and so i said boston i
thought boston was the closest city to
us that we hadn't both been to and so i
said nina this weekend we go to boston
it's wednesday on friday after your work
i'm going to pick you up we're going to
go to boston and then i brought danny
and his business partner at the time my
camera guys to help us film it that was
the start immediate action so here's
what happens when you do that when you
go up to the two percent difference you
go idea to action idea to action data
action
you start training it you start burning
into your nervous system you start
building momentum and then this is the
magic thing
your head starts working with your heart
your head instead of talking you down
from doing the crazy thing starts
thinking holy crap we committed to this
now i have to figure a way to do it now
i'm going to boston now we're going to
figure what am i going to do in boston
who am i going to connect with in boston
where are we going to stay in boston how
are we going to get to boston what's our
itinerary going to look like in boston
right your head now starts working with
you alongside your crazy vision instead
of the other way around because often
you make a decision feeling bold and
amazing unstoppable and then your head
talks you down from it so i believe
that the decisions that you make when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you the decisions that
you make when you're feeling bold
unstoppable crazy confident you decide
you're gonna do something those are
actually the right ones for you and then
your head gets to work and telling you
why you can't do it 99 of the rest of
your life is your head telling you that
you can't do it but you're not good
enough that you're not strong enough
that you're not capable enough you don't
have the skills beliefs mindset the
resources be able to do it right that's
the problem
so you make a decision and then the
immediate thing you have to do is do the
two percent difference take immediate
action on that thing don't go home and
plan don't plan to 100
the two percent difference immediate
action train yourself idea action idea
action idea action don't judge the idea
don't think it's crazy or too big or you
have to go research it don't just act on
it right now
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
my original teacher was jim rohn i met
him when i was 17
and i wanted to know why
all my fathers were broke because they
were good men
you know i loved all four of my fathers
and um
and i remember him saying tony we're all
equal as souls
but we're not equal in the marketplace
i was like what does that mean and he
said well think about it he goes you
need to become more valuable
if you want to have economic freedom he
said you have to work on yourself more
than anything else and you have to work
on it in a way where there's something
you can do for others better than anyone
else or at least more a better quality
and he gave me an example of like
working at mcdonald's and he said you
know if you work at mcdonald's
you know you make whatever it was in
those days five dollars an hour whatever
it was and he said you know i go yeah
but it seems so unfair and he goes yeah
and teachers i give example of teachers
and there's these billionaires you know
they make a billion dollars a year hedge
fund guy you know and he said tony the
guy you just mentioned he provided a 40
return last year
and that went to non-profits everything
else he said that means those
organizations double their money almost
every two years he is adding massive
value hundreds of billion dollars so he
made a billion he goes this person is
doing a job that anyone can learn in 20
minutes or half a day
so it's a beginning job he said you've
got you've got to think of it as one
thing it's all about adding value how
can you do more for others than anybody
else in the world and that
stuck with me i mean i was like i
decided i wanted to do more further than
anybody in the world in order to do that
i had a certain skills and i went after
those skills and i still do like it's a
never-ending thing if you think you're a
master you're full of it right so i
think that's probably some of the best
advice i've received at least on life
and business and direction and it
affected my mission great ideas are
never going to interrupt you they have
to be pursued and you if you don't
pursue them you're going to get what
everybody else has which is all this
fear all this uncertainty all this stuff
it won't work because everybody's
focused on what won't work what can't
happen why because they're afraid
they're afraid to fail they're afraid to
try and feel like they're not enough so
you got to stand guard of that mind by
feeding your mind
you know jim rohn used to say to me
success leaves clues if you want thing
to get better you got to get better if
you want things to change you got to
change but you got to do it deliberately
and consciously and he used to say to me
constantly said tony you've got to
constantly find a way to feed that mind
something that's got strategy in it
philosophy something that's going to
improve the quality of your life
and if you really learn it
you can help the people you love with
the things you learn
and so i got hooked and so i decided i'm
going to read a book a day i took a
speed reading course and i didn't read a
book a day but i read 700 books over the
period of seven years all in the area of
philosophy physiology emotion the things
to me that mattered most and what i
really try to do is each day try to use
something i learn not just read not just
let my
learning lead to knowledge you know jim
used to say if you let you learn to lead
in knowledge you become a fool
if you let you learn lead to action
that's when your life changes so i
started being aware of who was saying
what what i was taking in you know jim
used to say you know success leaves
clues if someone's successful they're
not lucky they're doing something
different than you figure out what
they're doing different he said the
first thing is find out what they're
reading
he said because he said i remember he
said me something funny he said find out
what poor people read and don't read it
and we said poor he didn't just mean
financially poor he meant people that
were unhappy people that were had no
sense of meaning in their life people
that were financially strapped because
they weren't managing to add value to
other people people that found
themselves not taking your relationships
their body poor isn't just money wealth
isn't just money it's emotional
spiritual everything he said so find out
what successful people do what wealthy
people read what happy people and read
that the difference between making it or
not is psychology and skill you need
both and honestly skill is the smaller
of the two i'm going to give you a ton
of strategies this week i'm gonna do
psychology first and you're gonna see
why as this day goes by because you're
gonna discover when people stand up and
we figure out what's the chokehold on
their business 80 percent of the time
it's going to be their psychology
the choke hold on the growth of your
business is the psychology and skills of
the leader
period
that's it
and if we change those two things skills
too marketing skills financial
intelligence recruiting training all
those things between those two don't get
me wrong we got to do the skills also
but i could give you every skill how
many of you learned before that was
invaluable from some source a mentor a
coach an event a university i don't know
what
and you were excited about it and then
you never actually follow through who's
done this before you say i
listen knowledge is not power
execution trumps knowledge every day of
the week
my goals make you execute i can't make
you but i can get you when you tap into
that part of yourself and that shift is
the most important shift of these few
days most of us in life we we work so
hard for things we think life's going to
be a certain way but as you're going to
discover life is never a straight line
you know we're taught that we think line
is just i'm going to go from here to
there but if you look in nature you
never see a straight line in real nature
but it's a straight line a human built
it and so it's a process of evolving of
growing dropping back growing dropping
back and and challenges are what really
grow us you know your life is a great
story you know every person's life is a
story the question is some people's
story is a warning some people's story
is an example right now you're an
example that's growing and expanding and
you have a chance to have this be the
most incredible life but it won't be a
life without challenge and the
challenges we're facing right now give
you an opportunity to grow like very few
generations you know i'm sure you've
heard of the great generation the world
war ii generation
if you watch a great movie if you read a
great book you know the size and the
power of the hero how much you become as
a hero is defined by how tough an
obstacle you face how difficult is the
villain the opponent and so sometimes
when i've been through the toughest
times in my life one of the questions
i've had to ask myself or note to myself
is ah i finally have a really worthy
opponent this is scaring the hell out of
me or this is challenging me this is
making me crazy but i also know of my
god in my soul that if i can push this
just like you've done in these years
you've pushed through tough times i'm
sure of many of them but as you push
through those you become more as you
become more something magical happens
you don't just grow
you expand in your spirit and your soul
and your capacity and your skill and all
of a sudden fear becomes less and less a
part of you all of us
we could take our work
and think of work as being like a gift i
i personally believe that one of the
greatest gifts outside my love that i
can give another human being is my labor
but there's three gifts of labor you
might have within your nature meaning
you can master anything but under stress
people tend to go back to their true
nature
and there are three gifts of labor that
you can give one of those gifts we might
call the gift of being an artist
or a talent or another word for be a
truly skilled producer
some people the reason you know this is
your gift is what you love to do is to
create a product or service and deliver
it to people and you're enamored by that
the woman over here who is doing the
work if you recall you know in hospice
she would be a perfect example of an
artist she's not in it she wants to make
money don't get me wrong but she would
never trade the money for the impact
so when someone is in it as an artist
and by the way most businesses are
started by artists
there's somebody who is an amazing
negotiator an amazing fashion designer
amazing code writer and they said i work
for this company and they don't do a
good job for customers and i can do a
better job i don't work for them and
they start their own company thinking
that the company is all driven just by
the sales or the negotiation or the code
or the fashion but a company is much
more complex than that especially as it
grows
so an artist is in it for the impact
and yes they want to make money don't
get me wrong but it's not the first
thing and they won't trade it when i
talk to artists about selling their
business they look at me like i'm trying
to sell their child
the second gift you might have
is the gift of being a manager leader
a manager leader is someone who lives to
manage people and processes they love to
figure out how to maximize a business by
changing the gears creating a new
process working with people and those
people love it now they are not artists
in that their talent or skill they're
not there delivering it directly to the
client they want to work on the people
that directly got they want to work on
the system that makes this business work
and so they think it differently they're
inspired by different things they make
different decisions
is one better or worse than the other
yes or no
no they're just different and by the way
you might say i have both those skills i
bet you do but they're not equal
because they're different types of
skills so you might have them both
but there's one that is your true nature
that when things are going well you're
going to go back to it when things are
really up you're going to go back to it
under stress and under excitement we
return to our nature by the way a great
company can't be great without great
artists talent who really deliver
extraordinary products or services a
company cannot maintain greatness and
grow unless they have some great manager
leaders who can run with the process and
the people they're both critical
components the third
choice of service the trigger gift you
can give is that of an entrepreneur
and while most of you in this room will
call yourself an entrepreneur and you
would be entrepreneurial
by this definition it's a little
different most people think of an
entrepreneur as anybody starts multiple
businesses no that's not true
some artists are multiple businesses
because they want to get all kinds of
things for all kinds of people some
managers want to do multiple businesses
so they feel like they have multiple
systems but entrepreneurs in it for one
thing
the juice of risk
they want to make money
and by the way an entrepreneur will they
sell this business yes or no
for the right price they'll sell
anything and their mindset is fit sell
it i'll start another one sell it i'll
buy another one
they are not attached they might enjoy
the product service that might be proud
of their product or service but they're
in it for the risk and they're the kind
of person that when they lose massively
they jump up dust themselves off and
want to do it again ultimately i really
believe
that the
probably the most i don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor
you think about your labor is your
energy it's your time it's your emotion
it's your intellect it's your spirit to
some extent and if you can find a way
where
what you do for a living activates that
sense of what you're made for then work
is not work whether you be in fiji or
whether you be in a an environment that
might be seemed less exciting and
promising in the moment trust me i've
worked in plenty of those too but with
the same level of excitement and passion
because i found what
turns me on that makes me feel alive
makes me feel like i'm doing something
that's worthwhile and on labor day i
think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
labor uh and my hope is to trigger you
to think about how could you turn your
labor into your love
i think it was uh mark twain has said
when your vocation becomes your vacation
that's when life becomes truly
magnificent and i'm privileged enough to
have that but i pursued it and one of
the secrets that i found and i know you
know this in your soul is that we all
know if you're going to be masterful at
something you don't show up you know as
the best in the world at something you
don't show up in environments that you
want to be in you get there because you
did things for thousands and thousands
of hours most of you know the concept of
mastery taking 10 000 hours that's an
arbitrary number but i'm sure you've
heard about you want to get really good
at something it's 10 000 hours because
when you do something enough with enough
intensity enough intention to constantly
get better when your labor is your love
and where your labor is something you
have to always get better at
then usually what happens is you get
these insights that allow you to serve
more but i also think that labor you
know we're talking about this weekend
what makes people fulfilled by their
labor is
is their motives for it if your motive
is just to make money or just to pay
your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money um the most fulfilled
human beings in my experience and i've
had the privilege of working with
literally four million people from 125
countries now around the world the
people that are most alive regardless of
the economics are people that have found
something that they really feel the
motive is more than just themselves you
know we all know what it feels like when
you're trying to do so for something for
someone you love and you're not doing it
as a trade you're not trying to get
something back you're just doing it
because it's what you're made for and
i always tell people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because life supports whatever else
supports life if you're part of life and
you're trying to do something it's going
to make your life better i think the
universe god whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is you
know
infinite intelligence gets connected to
you and it gives you insights
but i think if you're trying to serve
more than yourself more life than just
you
when things support more of life more of
life shows up to support you and that
might sound kind of airy fairy but it's
my experience you know when you're
trying to support your family when
suddenly i had four kids three of them
overnight
my life changed my intellect changed my
abilities changed because i was trying
to serve something more than just me
uh when i started really focusing how to
serve a community and then a country and
then humanity as corny as it may sound
you get insights you won't get when
you're just trying to somehow you know
make your labor happen or get the job
done so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people i think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at
labor as work
they look at as why should i have to
effort so much and in my experience
effort is the reward if you are doing
something you love it's there so if you
don't have it you might say tony that's
all wonderful you're in fiji and you do
what you love and i don't have that
thanks so much for giving me the lecture
i'm not coming from that place i'm come
from the place of saying you can
discover something that you're really
passionate about but in order to do it
you got to get out of the story of what
you can't do and you got to put yourself
on the line lifestyle's not about money
it's about two things
creativity and caring
it doesn't take money it just takes a
little creativity to think about those
you love and
think what would light them up
it will light you up more than anything
else i promise you
to surprise them to do beautiful special
things
little things
it makes people feel
important needed loved appreciated
what better way to invest
than invest in your relationships with
those you love
and you can't give joy to everybody else
that you love without giving joy to
yourself
and then there's another kind
the other kind is where you invest in
those you don't even know
not for stars on your chart
because you know it's right
it can be done with such a small amount
of money it's not money it's creativity
and caring
maybe it's animals that are abused maybe
it's old folks that people don't pay
attention to anymore
maybe it's
providing one surgery for someone who
has lost sight and can see again
provide water for a family you gotta
everyday feed and strengthen your body
and you gotta do something even in the
middle of covet if it's still there even
if it lockdown because if you don't take
over your body it affects your mind
doesn't it
i mean think about this
what is it that screws up everybody's
life
fear is the number one thing it keeps
people from doing what's necessary and
anger and rage welcome mobilize us if it
becomes part of your life on a regular
basis it destroys it so how do you
balance that out well
fear anger they're both physical aren't
they
think about what do you feel like if
you're really ever been so afraid that
your throat got really dry or you feel
this feeling in your gut
right that's physical
courage is also physical again courage
does not mean you're not afraid
courage means you're afraid but you do
it anyway right it's a it's a way of
being in your body so one of the things
that i started doing early on is
understanding and those of you who spent
four days with me you know day and night
because we did it it's in your body
still how to change the way you feel
instantly by a radical change in your
body and so i really want to recommend
you do something at least five days a
week first thing when you wake up in the
morning i don't it doesn't have to be an
hour workout even 30 minutes it can be
something as little as 5 or 10 minutes
there is not a day when i wake up i
shared with some of you this already
first thing i do i go outside if i'm
lucky enough to be at one of my homes
anyway i have homes in different parts
of the world because i've traveled the
world and done this i'm very fortunate
but i have a cold punch i've installed
in everyone 56 degrees and my home in
sun valley i know i don't have a cold
punch i don't need i walk through the
snow in the winter in the summer i walk
through the grass and i get in the river
and then
literally the river is usually about 39
to 42 degrees to give you an idea
every cell in your body is moved the
blood rushes through everything right
and i do it for two reasons there's
never a day i look forward to doing it i
don't go oh i can't wait to go in there
i do it number one because it transforms
your body the blood flow the lymph flow
is unbelievable from a health
perspective you just go in for a minute
pop out it's like a different world
right i don't care what it is or you
could take a freezing shower would be
the minimum way you could do this you
couldn't do this but it's about changing
your body so radically and it's also
about developing a simple daily
discipline
it's like i don't negotiate with myself
i tell my brain i don't go oh wait i'm
not ready or let me let me count to 10
or maybe i'll do it tomorrow
that pattern of thinking is what
destroys most people's lives and their
dreams you can settle for a life like
most people have or you can create your
dreams but to do it you need to be able
to push yourself so you need to train
yourself in little ways or it could be
just going and lifting weights and
you're going to do like 10 minutes of
pushing yourself or a sprint or really
fast walk anything because when you get
your blood pushing when you push beyond
what's comfortable
it develops this determination inside
you this sense of will that you will
then use everywhere else i always say if
you discipline yourself in one area of
your life you're going to be able to do
it even more in other areas you get
momentum momentum is everything so if
you train your mind great but you got to
change your body as well in some way and
i don't care again if it's five or ten
minutes will you really push yourself or
a full-blown workout it's got to get
there because when you do that regularly
you're going to find yourself having a
better mind the mind and body can't be
separated they're completely connected
you work on both of them you're going to
have a different world and you're not
going to be shut down when other people
like oh it can't be done just move i'll
handle it it's a different way of being
isn't it it's a purpose larger than
yourself that keeps you going if it's
only to meet your own needs you will
drop back into your comfort zone but
like you know for example you know one
of the great things that came out of
covid is i've spent most of my life as a
vagabond right because i travel all over
the earth so in most
years i travel to you know 115 cities
and as you know most my seminars are
multi-day seminars and i go to 12 to 16
countries you know like australia three
times
and so all of a sudden covet hits and i
had to adapt i found this way to adapt
and now i'm reaching ten dollars i mean
my largest seminar is now 900 000 people
versus 15 000. i was trying i did one
football stadium in 2019 with 38 000
people 40 000 people it was incredible
now that's a tiny seminar you know
because i couldn't put 900 000 people in
any stadium right so all this good comes
from that adaptation right figuring out
what to do but i think the other part of
it is you know during the same time when
the great gifts was i could find a way
to be home and still touch people's
lives so deeply and do it in a way that
was impactful i could see it and feel it
and in their home i could see their
children i mean it's been amazing and
now i do both i do hybrid i got a
thousand people in front of me and 197
countries all around me but one of the
other benefits was is we'd want to have
a daughter and i told my wife i'm not
having a kid after 50. i don't want to
show up at high school reunion and be 70
years old but now i got an i've got a
night i've got a 48 year old daughter
and a nine-month-old daughter to give
you an idea i got five kids of my
granddads but my daughter
like all the things i've ever done for
myself biohacking and health and all
that stuff like
now i'll be 80 at her high school
reunion so like i gotta use these things
for a different reason and so that
doesn't let me get to a certain level
and stand there it's like man i you know
i gotta be 92 to 102 range in order to
do that i gotta know every tool in the
toolbook to turn around so gave me even
more drive
and then what comes out of that now is i
can help anybody i mean you know this is
my new book by the way it's called life
force
it's coming out february the 8th but you
can pre-order it now on amazon or go to
tony robbins.com
but the point is it's like i want to
know every single tool like i got
totally obsessed even more than i
normally have because it's like okay i
got a higher purpose i got all my
grandkids all my children but now i got
my daughter it's like i gotta have these
tools dealing with the loss of someone
you care about is probably the most
difficult thing of all i would say maybe
uh as a child seeing
the level of frustration between my
parents you know i had four different
fathers and watching them kind of um you
know accept whatever life gave them as a
it's why a lot of my drive came about is
seeing my father's
be berated by my mother who i love
dearly um and just watching them break
down like you know
i'm probably the single most
painful event of my life but also shaped
me in such a beautiful way was when i
was 11 years old we had no money for
food it was thanksgiving which in
america is a you know big holiday feast
and so we've been without food before
we'd have crackers and butter and you
know we survived but we weren't gonna
have a thanksgiving feast and there's
knock out the door and i go the door and
there's this giant guy there with
groceries in each hand and he had a pot
beside him on the ground with an
uncooked turkey and
i i just like i said uh who are you here
for he goes i'd like to speak to your
father and my mom and dad were yelling
at each other saying things that you
could never take back and i'm trying to
make sure my younger brother and sister
they're five and seven years younger
wouldn't hear any of this
and
that day changed my life because i
thought it was gonna be the most
exciting day
dad dad go to the front what is it
that's it's for you you answered no it's
for you i remember open the door and i
was just so excited to see my father be
happy like we're gonna have a feast this
is gonna be incredible and he got angry
and he's like we don't accept charity he
went to slam the door in the man's face
and the man's foot was there so it
bounced off his foot
he still opened the groceries he's like
sir i'm just the delivery guy he said
it's it's not charity everybody has a
tough time someone bought this and
they're sending it to you as a gift
my father said we don't take charity
goes to close the door again
this time the guy's shoulder was there
also so it bounced off again
and then i was standing right there and
there's this moment i'll never get where
this man looked at my father and he
looked at me and he said sir don't let
your ego make your family
uh
uh suffer
and the veins on my dad's face on the
side of his neck i'll never forget the
bulge i like his face turned red i
thought i was gonna punch him in the
face and then there's this moment my
dad's shoulders dropped he took the
groceries slammed the door didn't say
thank you
and stormed off and i almost remember
thinking
like how come he's not happy you know
you talk about pain it's like i love my
father so much and
he there's basically three decisions i
think everybody makes in their life that
whether aware of it or not moment to
moment i figured this out afterwards
because i was so obsessed with what's
wrong because he eventually left our
family and that was the most painful
thing i ever have so it's like feeling
like i failed you know i blame myself
like why couldn't i get through to my
father when i was 11 years old
but later on it helped me understand the
three decisions are first you gotta
decide what to focus on every moment of
your life there's something grabbing
your focus and you don't experience life
you experience the part of life you
focus on right what's wrong is always
available so is what's right right
and there are different kinds of focus
and my dad's focus that day was really
on what he hadn't done and i know that
because he kept muttering it and i
hadn't taken care of his family there's
no funny for thanksgiving somebody got
to give us charity and then the second
decision you make about once you focus
on something is what does it mean
is this the end or the beginning if you
think it's the end of a relationship
you're going to behave different than
it's the beginning right um my dad's
meaning was that he was worthless and so
then the third decision is what do i do
which
whatever meaning you come up with
creates the emotions which affects what
you do and what he decided to do is
leave your family but for me it was like
this is amazing i mean
you know we are having thanksgivings you
know this a this is incredible we have
food what a concept and then the meaning
though is what changed my whole life
which was
wow
strangers care
that completely changed my life that
painful experience
i couldn't deny that somebody who wanted
no credit
delivered this food to my family and so
what i decided to do is say someday i'm
going to do this for another family so
when i was 17 i had two families and it
was a euphoric experience i went in
jeans and a t-shirt i didn't go like the
delivery guy but i wanted to see the
face of the people and then the next
year was four people and then it was
eight and literally my thing was
doubling i little company and then i got
to a million people a year and i got to
four million people a year then i was
doing money master the game
i'm interviewing these billionaires jay
and i'm watching congress cut food
stamps it's now called the snap program
by i think it was six billion dollars so
every family that actually needs food
and my family was one of those back then
they all have to come up with a week's
worth of food out of every month so i
was like call my team and i said how
many people have i fed in my lifetime i
didn't know that was 42 million meals i
was like this is pretty cool and i was
like what if i said 50 million people
like my entire lifetime in one year and
i was like what if i did a hundred
million what if i found a billion people
in 10 years so that was seven years ago
we're at 850 million meals right i'm
gonna hit the billion earlier than what
i promised and targeted and then i've
got a sustainable approach but i tell
you that because
my worst day was my best day
my the most painful day the day where i
felt i could do the least where i found
infinite
led me to have new understandings new
skills new capacities new drives new
hunger i mean would i really be feeding
100 million people a year 100 million
meals a year if i was well-fed as a
child probably not and i'd love to
believe i'm such a perfect person but no
i'm just i just know what suffering
feels like so i don't want anybody else
to suffer you know so i think sometimes
the suffering experiences of our life if
we don't let them crush us we let them
drive us they they actually become the
best day in your life and taking your
worst day and making your best day is a
beautiful target for anybody why is
identity so important for us to shape a
positive powerful identity well first of
all so everybody understands what i mean
by identity is we all have a way of
identifying ourselves we have a way of
labeling ourselves
so most of us came up with our labels
based on how we behaved
but really smart people can do stupid
things really nice people can be mean
mean people can be nice and so if you
judge yourself too soon and most
people's identity their labels for
themselves who they think they are has
been based on their past and often many
years ago and so they don't update it so
the the metaphor i'd give for identity
is like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals
so if you like if you took a temperature
in the room and said 68 degrees is my
comfort zone physically emotionally
financially i want more in my
relationship i want more physically
energy-wise i want more financially in
my career but this is what i'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa
you're a 68 degree or what the hell are
you doing we've all experienced that all
of a sudden you go i'm not going to live
like this anymore i'm not going to be in
this relationship i'm not going to be
fat like this
boom and you get this drive and you
start to change but what most people
don't understand
is it happens on the upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 degrees
financially emotionally spiritually
whatever the metaphor is and then what
happens you're going to say hey you're
bringing us who the hell do you think
you are you're not a 98 degree
right get back to 68 and if nothing else
the heaters stop you lose your drive and
that'll drift you back and not enough
the air conditioner can kick on you
start to kind of sabotage yourself till
you get back to your comfort zone so
unless you expand your identity
changes temper it's like when someone
says to me i've stopped smoking it's
been eight days
i go one count and i say why are you
counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time
like if i went to somebody and i said to
you hey you know
louis you want a cigarette you're not
going to say what brand is it you know
no
i'm not a smoker notice how people i'm
not one of those that's not my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look lance
armstrong who has a mixed identity now
in the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win so when he was told he had
cancer
in his lungs in his brain and in his
testicles and he rides a bike
and he's gonna die
his answer was no i'm a champion i find
the way i will find the answer and he
did now unfortunately he bent the rules
around the sport and it kind of ruined
his reputation obviously but that
mentality his identity is why he
survived other people told they have
cancer and they're like it's over they
give up they start arranging their
affairs and so that psychological
difference is the number one thing i
work with people on because unless you
expand your identity you're going to
basically keep where you are you might
improve a little or not you might go up
and down a bit but you're going to stay
within a realm if you're going to have
an explosive breakthrough to another
level physically mentally financially
spiritually then we got to not only give
you the tools
we got to shift that internal sense of
who you really are and have you find
that you are more than anything that's
ever happened to you that you can handle
whatever shows up even if it's
incredibly scary or uncomfortable when i
was growing up i grew up very poor and
i'm the oldest of three and i had to do
all the shopping all the grocery
shopping on my bicycle come home make
the meal and i was happy with all that
but then right when you wanted to be
done with your work and go watch sports
or do something great i had to wash the
dishes so i swore someday i will never
do the labor of washing dishes i will
afford a dishwasher i will find some way
to not have to do dishes i tell you
there's a background because when i told
him it couldn't be a furniture mover he
looks down and goes home only one other
job left
dishwashing
now dishwashing in india is a different
labor than you might picture in your
kitchen
you're in this ashram and i report and
there's these milk solids and yogurts on
the floor and you're standing in your
bare feet and you're taking these filthy
dishes coming across and it's four hours
a day for six or seven days i'm telling
you i was so angry i was so mad at
myself that i was there as matter was
and i was washing these dishes and upset
and plus i was a vegan and you know i
didn't like the fact there was milk on
the floor i was judgmental about
everything in the middle of all this
stuff after about an hour of being angry
i got tired of being angry and some part
of me kicked in and goes damn whatever
you do you're the best at it why don't
you be the best damn dishwasher so i
started washing these dishes with a
frenzy i'm like come on guys speed this
thing up
and something magical happened
the thing that i thought was most
disgusting and
filled with labor and work became play
and i started to laugh at myself and i
thought what an ego jerk you are
to think that you're below washing some
dishes
and then i got beyond my ego and jerk
into why not just enjoy whatever you do
and then when you do
all of a sudden it's not work anymore
and that was my great spiritual
breakthrough i eventually did meet with
his guru and tried to straighten him out
but um he didn't think very much an 18
year old kid straightened him out he
laughed quite a bit he did talk to my
partners and said i think you guys
should just you know keep teaching what
you're teaching and fit for life went on
to be one of the most successful books
in history uh but i can't claim credit
for that as a part of that little piece
but i will tell you that if you can
get over what if you can get yourself to
love to do the stuff you hate to do then
there's no limit to the success you can
have in your life
if you can take the things that you're
afraid you'd have to do to succeed in
your business or to succeed in your life
or
uh to succeed in your relationship there
are things everybody doesn't want to do
and the more focused you're on how
you're not going to do that the more
life seems to bring those things up for
you and makes them barriers for most of
my life like help people achieve
accomplish everything achieve make it
happen and if you ask me i was fulfilled
it's of course i was and i was i loved
it but
there's different levels of fulfillment
right if you've never smelled a rose and
someone's telling you what a rose is
like you think you know to experience it
yeah so i had this experience in india i
go about every two years and there's a
friend of mine there's built this
amazing facility and he had like a
quarter million people showing up for
his event they expected they would have
you know i think a hundred thousand
people and a quarter million people
showed up and then a million two by the
next morning
and the guy that was there is a really
smart guy and so i had a conversation
with his son
and he was thanking me for all this work
i've done he goes tony of all the things
you've taught me he said i think maybe
the most important thing is all the ways
i can change my state i can get unstuck
i can i can get myself to follow through
he goes it is priceless and he really
thanked me and i said well i really
appreciate it and more importantly i'm
glad you're using it right he goes but i
just have one little thing i'd like to
ask you
because you know you talk about if
you're in a peak state you get peak
performance or if you're an energy rich
state a high energy state you're going
to produce differently than a low energy
state or a lousy state i said yeah
he goes well what if you call those high
energy states beautiful states
i said that's great because it's not
just happiness a beautiful state could
be excitement it could be gratitude it
could be love it could be kindness it
could be warmth i mean there's a million
beautiful states it's any high energy
state where no one has to tell you what
to do you'll do the right thing
so he goes okay i said sylvia beautiful
state's great and then he goes what if
we took all those lousy states those low
energy states those
those types of states and what we call
those suffering
and then when he said that you probably
kind of like what you experienced it
like nod at me a little bit it's like
suffering
i don't like suffering i don't suffer
but i do have times when i'm frustrated
or stressed or overwhelmed so i couldn't
deny it so i was like okay yeah those
would be suffering states i felt this
little trap going on in me and i said
why do you say this yes he goes tony
because i think it's the most important
distinction you've made but i like to
use some other words around it you guys
because i've set a spiritual vision for
myself
so what's that he said
my goal is to live in a beautiful state
every day no matter what he goes to me
that would be the most gorgeous life
because you know people have everything
and they're miserable they're pissed off
they're frustrated and so forth because
you deal with them all the time i said
that is brilliant i changed it slightly
for me i'd say
life is too short to suffer
to me that's where it starts life's too
short and silver how could i possibly
suffer when i've been able to live this
magnificent life it's just the mind if
you don't direct this thing it directs
you it's like you use the mind or it
uses you you use stress or stress uses
you yeah and so i said you know okay so
how am i going to do that because
there's one thing to say it yeah it's
going to develop the habits yeah right
and when i found myself like getting on
a plane and you know i have my own plane
now obviously but
the time i used to go to australia four
times a year and i'd fly on qantas and
when i moved to florida it became 20
hours each way like a 40-hour trip for
one little visit yeah and i remember
getting on the plane and being so
stressed and i thought to myself tony
how could you be stressed you're flying
in a plane you can fall asleep you can
you know it's not my size bed obviously
but i'm first class and i'm very lucky
it's like come on what are you what are
you whining about in your head and i
realized what it was was that they had
no internet
so now i'm flying for 40 hours and
what's happening all my slacks all my
emails all my texts all it's all growing
fortunately i got this resolved in my
head before i got like lucky enough to
have my own plane and i remember when i
got worked out i got on a plane i flew
from here to l.a
i've gone on plane la and then you know
the captain comes on and goes uh this is
captain stubblebine it's gonna be a
beautiful flight to sydney and then he
said something i never heard before he
said today i have a special announcement
and it's this we have for the first time
in history of qantas internationally
literally people stood up on the plane
and cheered and
[Laughter]
so we all open up our ipads our phones
are everything we got right we're all
typing doing our stuff on social media
and nine minutes later what do you think
happened it breaks down it crashes when
you think it turns on again
never
the thing that struck me out and it's
changed my life is i looked around me
and people were angry they were cursing
what the hell's wrong with this airline
they can't get this [ __ ] right
i looked around i was like
this is amazing nine minutes ago this
was a miracle now it's already an
expectation
and then i realized
all the unhappiness comes from all those
expectations you can't help have the
mind expect but you can direct it
and when you expect something that's not
met you get upset
yeah and it's like
what if the only time i'm happy is when
everybody meets my expectations i got
105 companies i got 3 800 employees on
four continents what are the chance of
someone screwing up right now meaning
doing something different than i think
they should 100
so it's like i need to make it so that
other people don't have to behave a
certain way for me to be happy the
secret to living is giving because
you're never going to be happy by what
you get
you'll get it you'll be excited for a
while for how long
but if you keep giving you'll become
something unique that whether other
people know it or not you will know who
you are people can take away all your
things they can't take away who you
become as a man or as a woman as a soul
so business is a spiritual game how can
i do more for others than anybody else
how can i do it consistently i can do it
better how can i fall in love with my
clients and to over deliver levels they
can't even imagine
and develop this beautiful relationship
of such joy it isn't a transaction there
are transactions involved but you're not
doing it for the transaction you're
doing it to make that difference in
their business or their life
when you're driven by a mission more
than yourself you get a level of energy
that people just trying to take of
themselves will never have
so my heartfelt wish for you my dear
friends is remember what business is
it's a spiritual game
it's about what can you give not what do
you get
you'll get plenty
if you'll give much more than you expect
to receive
if you do that you'll have more than
money
you have a life of incredible meaning
and your life will be blessed uh right
now you know out of covid so many people
been shot down terrible place and you
know i'm sure you've seen that um drug
overdoses are the largest they've ever
been in history is over a hundred
thousand people last year suicides one
out of four kids under the age of 30
according to the cdc whether they're
accurate i don't know have considered
suicide sometime in the last two years
because we all need a compelling future
we need to look something look forward
to so stanford came to me and their
genetics lab has been doing research on
depression
and
what they found was that on by doing
meta studies is only 40 of the people
who go in for therapy who they get drugs
and therapy together usually only 40
percent make any improvement 60 don't
improve at all that's not a lot more
than what you get on some placebos
and so
they approached me and said a couple of
people went through one of your programs
one was clinically depressed they're not
anymore but we don't have any science on
this would you be one of us do a science
test i said sure so they came out to the
state destiny seminar i do which helps
people to change their values and belief
structures i don't tell them what they
need to be they figure out what it needs
to be and it changes the way you
perceive life the way you experience
life how you feel what you do it's a
rewiring of your model of the world
basically in six days
and so they said we're going to model
this after the greatest breakthrough
they found in science and no one able to
follow up on about two years ago johns
hopkins did a study on depression
and they gave people psilocybin right
which comes from magic mushrooms and
they did therapy for 30 days and at the
end of it 53 of the people were
depression free 30 days later never
happened like when we say 40 are helped
the average amount of help is 50 less
depressed right that's what the average
some people completely turn around some
people enroll in this one 53 of the
people so it's four times the result of
any drug that ever been done but
unfortunately psilocybin is not legal so
they're still working on that and they
said we're going to copy that exact
study and we're going to have a group
that they compared to which is didn't go
to the seminar the comparison group is
going to do gratitude journaling and so
forth because positive psychology talks
about that and they said that's probably
what this seminar does it's just
positive thinking well the cool thing
was when it came out the results were so
amazing at stanford that they went and
had two new additional double blind
people do the research because it just
seems so ridiculous
at the end of oh the first week 63
percent of people had no who had no
depression symptoms at the end of six
weeks it can increase through time a
hundred percent of the people had no
no depression symptoms nineteen percent
of the people had uh through suicidal
ideation zero had suicidal ideation it
blows away any study it just came out
it's coming out next week in the
psychiatric journal which is general
america medic association
are the two top journals in the field
they can't even believe it so they're
going to do more and there's
the actual scientific article says this
is more powerful than any drug therapy
or any forms of normal therapy combined
and what are we doing
we're getting people to change basically
those three questions to some extent
because your values control what you
focus on
if you're
security driven and you're here down in
my basement right now you're like
where's the exit right you came down to
slide like how do i get out of here
right if you're adventure driven you
don't care you don't even know where it
is so your focus is controlled by your
values and your belief systems right the
meaning of things is controlled by your
belief systems so those three decision
making things you know what i'm going to
focus on what doesn't mean what i'm
going to do shift and one good example
of this j is maybe your audience can
relate to this
so if we just took three patterns
so let's say focus most people have a
focus either on what they have or what's
missing we both we all do both
but what do you think most people focus
on more often what they have or what's
missing what's missing that's right
now
even achievers do that
like it's not like somebody's not
successful it's one of the reasons you
see these achievers that no matter what
they do it's never enough
because think about if you're always
focusing what's missing from your life
how can you sustain happiness
it's software that will not allow that
you'll feel happy for a little moment
you'll notice it's missing again
um what do you think's more often people
focus on what they can control or can't
control what they can't control yeah in
my seminars it's can control that's why
they go
i want to learn how to take control of
my body or my finances or my business or
whatever it is so it's the opposite but
the average person it's what they can't
control and with covid there's so much
you can't control around you that people
really sunk in that well how's someone
gonna feel just everyone think about it
if you're constantly focused on what's
missing from your life and what you
can't control
and i'll add one more
do you focus more on the past
the present or the future we all do all
three but we tend to have one we focus
more on where do you think more people
focus
that's right
and achievers focus on the future
and happy people in the present it's
about growing and giving i mean that's
overly simplistic but that's what i want
for her it's like you know it's about
laughing loving growing giving
you know and giving passionately and
generously and graciously it doesn't i
don't mean just money i mean of your
presence
you know it's very easy to say hello and
not be there it's very easy to say i
love you and you know it's just a habit
you know about you know depending on
which studies you read about 47 to 52 of
things we do are just habit the cool
thing about habit is it allows you other
things like you know trying to drive a
stick shift car in the beginning is way
it's overwhelming now it's one thing i
can do 20 other things right
but the problem with it is
technology has made us become more and
more habitual
and less and less connected
and so for my daughter i wanted her to
experience love that's what life is to
me and when you are loving you have to
grow to keep loving and you when you're
growing and you're loving you're gonna
give and to me if that's all she does if
she learns that life is not
what you're here to get it's what you're
going to give that you're being called
to find what you're called for and i
don't know what you'll be called for she
you know may she might sing she might
draw art she might just be a mom she's
not just one of the most important
things in life she might i don't know
what she'll do and i have no frame of
reference about how she's going to do it
i have only one frame of reference she's
going to be a person that's earned it
and she's going to be a person who's
proud of herself because the urn part to
me is where the pride comes it's like i
have this amazing life you could take
away all the toys and things that i have
you couldn't change who i've become as a
man yeah and and also because i never
had those things and i earned those
things there's there's the stories and
the examples and you know what it's like
right to conquer all the challenges to
get there i want my daughter to have all
those experiences but to me life is love
and life is growing and giving it's
really that's what the whole game is
about as far as i'm concerned and if you
want more fire and espresso videos check
out the one that we recently did the
link is right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there